e andare incontro al futuro con la
determinazione non soltanto di credere
alle vuoi
quando di fuggire da
oggi vi voglio raccontare una storia
futura una storia e di una
trasformazione sociale che io penso
avverrà rapidamente rapidamente in
relazione alle scale che vediamo e che
ci permette di analizzare e di capire
come affrontare questo cambiamento che
sarà appunto
secondo me molto rapido questa storia
futura
io analizzo e cerco di capirla
raccontandola a me stesso per primo e
poi raccontando a voi perché la vivremo
insieme in un futuro che andremo a
costruire e parto proprio dalla mia
esperienza personale perché ogni storia
che ci raccontiamo non può che partire
da quella che viviamo contemporaneamente
questa trasformazione della nostra
società da quella che è attualmente a
quella che sarà in futuro io la chiamo
la network society e sono partito nel
cercare di capire come sarà la forma del
futuro proprio parlando con i miei figli
che così come me così come voi così come
i vostri figli vivranno e costruiranno
questo futuro loro mi chiedono quali
sono le prospettive che potranno vivere
chiedono quali sono le ambizioni le
opportunità che il mondo offrira a loro
e siccome io insegno analizzo costruisco
fenomeni esponenziali fenomeni che
partono lentamente per poi arrivare alla
coscienza comune arrivare di fronte a
tutti noi
improvvisamente se non siamo attenti a
quello che succede attorno o ben
presente quanto sia complesso e quanto
sia difficile
capire i segnali deboli di un futuro che
si avvicina la maniera quindi che vado
ad analizzare il futuro è una maniera
diversa da quella che vediamo raccontata
dai giornali o che vediamo raccontata
dai dalle televisioni è una maniera
nuova che spero anche voi condividerete
la società attorno a noi cambia
apparentemente lentamente e questi
cambiamenti sono avvenuti in passato e
in epoche che abbiamo deciso di chiamare
in una certa maniera
l'epoca dei faraoni quando venivano
costruite le piramidi e le epoche
successive l'epoca dei faraoni
quando gli schiavi venivano prese a
decine di migliaia perché anno dopo anno
costruissero monumenti meravigliosi che
ancora adesso ammiriamo è un'epoca che è
finita non perché questi schiavi si sono
guardati in faccia e hanno detto questo
non è giusto vogliamo ribellarci è
un'epoca che è finita per ragioni
diverse
il medioevo che è caratterizzato da una
gerarchia fe due finale di rapporti di
vassallaggio e di imperio è un'epoca che
è finita
non perché sono finiti i cavalieri
medievali che dovessero dominare i
vassalli non è finita perché si è andato
a decidere a priori quale doveva essere
il nuovo contratto sociale o perché la
rivoluzione francese ha risvegliato le
coscienze di tutti e oggi viviamo in un
epoca industriale dove molti vanno a
vedere sfide particolari difficoltà di
continua crescita produttiva o di
sfruttamento delle risorse naturali un
epoca industriale che sta tra
mando si affatica in un'epoca che vuole
chiamarsi post industriale e che si
confronta con rivoluzioni culturali
rivoluzioni demografiche e democratiche
ma anche questa non finirà per un
risveglio di coscienza a trasformarsi in
una nuova società qualunque sia questa e
in un qualunque momento questo avvenga
sia nelle trasformazioni precedenti che
in quella che vedremo in futuro
la chiave è stata una chiave tecnologica
e quella che precede il cambiamento è
quello che rende possibile il
cambiamento
le persone gli individui i gruppi coloro
che sognano il cambiamento certamente si
rendono conto dell'ingiustizia che gli
schiavi fossero scontenti era chiaro
nella società egiziana che i vassalli
potessero tentare di fare meglio e
chiaramente raccontato nelle favole dove
il figlio più piccolo della famiglia se
ne va e alla fine sposa la principessa è
una concreta e rappresentazione delle
ambizioni inespresse e inesprimibili di
quella società
ma finché non è stata scoperta la forza
del vapore gli idrocarburi o l'energia
atomica su cui in parte si basa la
nostra società oggi non è stato
possibile costruire una forma di società
che permettesse a quelle ambizioni
individuali culturali o di un nuovo
contratto sociale di realizzarsi cosa
succederà quindi tra poco
quali sono le chiavi di lettura del
futuro
quali sono i pilastri che sosterranno il
cambiamento che sta arrivando
intanto ve ne accenno e vi do una
lettura iniziale per poi darvi alcune
alcuni stimoli alcune provocazioni
perché possiate ragionarci su se vi fa
piacere
e se condividete questa analisi oppure
di ribattere che no non sarà così e ce
ne saranno altre naturalmente ma intanto
io vi voglio elencare quattro pilastri
di questo cambiamento
ognuno di questi quattro pilastri che vi
elencherò hanno la stessa caratteristica
ed è per questo che ho dato il nome di
network society di quella che verrà tra
poco perché opposto a quello che vediamo
oggi che è una gerarchia centralizzata
ognuno di questi elementi ha
caratterizzato da una distribuzione
decentralizzata
ed è questo che produce quell'effetto di
rete che vedremo attorno a noi vediamo
per prima quindi la produzione la
distribuzione e l'utilizzo dell'energia
oggi l'energia che utilizziamo nasce
dagli idrocarburi alla maggior parte un
po dall'atomo
ma ci sono già oggi proiezioni che
vedono l'energia solare entro il 2030
quindi poco più di dieci anni da oggi 15
anni diciotto anni da oggi soddisfare al
100 per cento le necessità di energia
della società non ha i consumi di oggi
ai consumi cresciuti proiettati di
allora l'energia solare la cui
efficienza aumenta alla stessa maniera
esponenziale che abbiamo visto
realizzarsi negli ultimi 45 hunt anni
con l'informatica è una modalità
distribuita di produzione dell'energia
non c'è bisogno anche se ci sono
progetti che lo prevedono di fare
centrali enormi che producano il
fabbisogno di un'intera regione o di
un'intera nazione o addirittura di un
intero continente
quando vedete raccontare che copriremo
il sahara di pannelli solari per poi
portare attraverso superconduttori
transoceanici attraverso il mediterraneo
in europa
tutta l'energia elettrica che serve non
solo questo progetto sarebbe molto
complicato e molto fragile ma
assolutamente non necessario perché come
sappiamo si può mettere pannelli solari
sulle case di tutti si può mettere
pannelli solari in campagna
tranquillamente distribuito e ci sono
paesi che già lo stanno facendo in modo
massiccio come per esempio la germania
vediamo il secondo pilastro la
produzione di cibo
oggi parliamo di industria agricola di
agri business
un modo centralizzato di produrre
cereali di produrre vegetali di produrre
anche carne in modo appunto
industrializzato dove abbiamo bisogno di
standardizzare ibridare e di seminare
per raccogliere quantità enormi di
il cibo uniformato che poi deve essere
trasportato su grandissime distanze
opposto a questo ci sono già delle
modalità di crescita di vegetali in una
maniera distribuita che riproducono un
po quello che il concetto dell'orto
controllabile non solo in campania ma
anche in un ambiente urbano all'interno
di container da trasporto questi
container utilizzando lampade led e
lampade ad infrarossi permettono in
coltivazione idroponica quindi
utilizzando pochissima acqua e
pochissimo terreno di dare una resa
molto superiore a quello che si può
ottenere adesso in assenza di pesticidi
e in assenza di interventi radicali di
ibridazione o di modificazione genetica
che altrimenti in l'industria agricola
tradizionale sono necessari
la cosa più importante di questo
approccio è che trasforma l'agricoltura
da una produzione proporzionale all'area
coperta ad una proporzionale al volume
utilizzato e quindi non è più questione
è che non ho abbastanza terreno o che
dobbiamo lasciare terreni incolti perché
questi possano riguadagnare la fertilità
che avevano perso attraverso lo
sfruttamento industriale ma in ogni
città possiamo prendere un edificio alto
dieci piani e due piani di questo
dedicarlo alla crescita del cibo
consumato all'interno dell'edificio
stesso
oppure di avere una casa dove
semplicemente sotto terra si fa crescere
il cibo necessario
il terzo pilastro è quello della
produzione degli oggetti fisici
tradizionalmente chiamata la produzione
industriale
anche questa oggi è centralizzata
addirittura su scala planetaria
probabilmente il 70 80 per cento degli
oggetti tecnologici che abbiamo qua è
stato prodotto in cina e attraverso una
complicatissima catena di distribuzione
realizzata e trasportata in tutto il
mondo incluso questo luogo perché poi
venisse acquistato è utilizzato la nuova
tecnologia della stampa 3d che permette
di realizzare oggetti localmente dove la
complessità del design è il valore
aggiunto ma la complessità della
realizzazione è assolutamente
indipendente dalla dalla scala costa
uguale stampare un cubo di materiale
stupido quanto stampare un oggetto
bellissimo complicatissimo e utilissimo
e oggi siamo sicuramente agli inizi ma
ci sono stampanti sempre più sofisticate
che permettono di realizzare insieme a
materiale di supporto circuiti elettrici
addirittura materiale biologico e
andremo a avere un'infrastruttura
distribuita invece che centralizzata di
produzione che appunto costituisce il
terzo pilastro di questa visione del
network society
il quarto e ultimo è quello della
finanza che è essa stessa tecnologia
quando è stata inventata la moneta come
unità di scambio unità di
immagazzinamento di valore
e stato un grosso salto tecnologico in
avanti ha permesso un miglioramento
della qualità della vita umana è quello
che vediamo oggi che sono le
vicissitudini finanziarie dovute alla
complessità dei derivati o alla mancanza
di regolamento per certuni all'eccessivo
regolamento per certi altri e del
comportamento delle banche o delle
autorità monetarie centrali non può
trovare risposta in un ritorno al
passato
abbandonando tutto quello che abbiamo
finora costruito così come la risposta
ai problemi industriali non può essere
quello di abbandonare le tecnologie che
abbiamo scoperto il passaggio da una
gestione centralizzata della finanza ad
una gestione distribuita della finanza
che non è più dipendente da decisioni
che si presuppone autonome e
indipendenti ma molto spesso
politicamente influenzate e strumentali
può trovare risposta nell'innovazione
matematica tecnologica appunto applicata
alla finanza uno degli esempi del della
quale i bitcoin bitcoin è un tipo di
moneta elettronica anonima sicura e non
tracciabile la cui produzione non è in
mano ad un'autorità centrale ma è
distribuita così come i protocolli di
scambio di file moderni non sono
dipendenti da server centrali spegnendo
i quali si ferma lo scambio e permettono
legalmente o illegalmente di scambiare
dati così l'infrastruttura di bitcoin
non è dipendente da un server centrale e
permette ad individui o gruppi gruppi di
individui di operare autonomamente per
effettuare quegli scambi di cui hanno
bisogno
abbiamo visto quindi quattro pilastri e
vi invito naturalmente di verificare
quello che ho detto di approfondire
perché vediate con i vostri occhi la
potenza letteralmente rivoluzionaria di
questi di queste tecnologie fondamentali
che porteranno al cambiamento societario
che vi ho descritto e quindi di
chiedervi così come sto facendo io quale
sarà la forma di questo futuro quale
sarà la forma della network society dove
il carburante delle automobili
elettriche non è prodotta più
centralmente ma è prodotta
individualmente come sarà passata questa
cosa se lo stato ha bisogno di produrre
il 60 per cento del costo del carburante
in tasse e quello è il prodotto del
vostro trasporto come sarà la forma del
futuro nel momento in cui la finanza non
è più controllata cioè centralmente
quando gli individui potranno in base
alla reciproca fiducia che hanno o non
hanno in uno o nell'altro concedere
mutui concedere prestiti e non ci sarà
più la banca che decide
che cosa debba succedere chi può averlo
o chi non può averlo che cosa succederà
alle industrie alimentari attuali quando
la produzione di cibo potrà essere
delocalizzata potrà essere distribuita
potrà essere rivoluzionata in base ai
principi che vi ho descritto
io ritengo che sarà un cambiamento
radicale un cambiamento rivoluzionario
verso appunto la network society che voi
e io insieme ai miei figli
vivremo vi ringrazio